Which activities are the most
effective at different levels
of competence in a language?
So the relationship between
learning activities
and where we are in the
language. I'm often asked, "What
do you do to learn a language?"
"What do I do when I'm starting out?"
"What do I do if I want to
break through the plateau?"
We are all at different
levels in the language.
And therefore, to some extent,
our learning activities will vary.
What is my situation?
Because I can only talk about what I do.
So first of all, when it comes to the sort
of levels in a language, there are some
recognized reference points, like
the Common European Framework of
Reference, which has six levels of
skill, you know, A1, A2, which is a
beginner, B1, B2, which is intermediate,
and C1, C2, which is advanced.
And these can be for writing, for
speaking, for reading, for listening.
To some extent, it gives you an idea
of what that level corresponds to.
But I have a lot of trouble with that.
I prefer to see our levels in a
language are sort of on a continuum.
When we start, we're very much
influenced by our own language.
We're sort of translating from our own
language structures that we think in,
in terms of our own language,
and gradually over time, we sort of
get more comfortable
in this other language.
Some people talk about "interlanguages,"
sort of a language that we use when
we're sort of in between the new language
and languages that we already know.
I don't think that's particularly helpful.
I think we just gradually get better and
there's sort of infinite steps on this
gradient. And also we might be better in
listening or in reading or in speaking.
And so to arbitrarily say, you know, "I'm a
B2" or "I'm a B1," I'm reluctant to do that.
And while I say that,
it is a handy reference.
So I always think in terms of getting to
sort of a B2 level, which to me is sort
of fluent to the extent that I can use
the language comfortably. Knowing that
I'm going to make mistakes. Knowing that
there are going to be some things that I
don't understand. But I'm communicating.
To me, that's sort of you're launched
now. Whereas beginner to me, either
you are a total beginner, like zero,
and I'll tell you what I do when I'm
at zero, or you're still very much
struggling to get a toehold in the
language, that's the sort of beginner.
Then you've got B2, which to me
is sort of the launching point.
And then somewhere in between those two
is the sort of B1, genuine intermediate
level. In Canada, for whatever
reason, they came up with 12 levels.
They call it the "Canadian Language
Benchmarks," on the theory that you can
tie a particular job to level five.
And they try to describe in
great detail what you are able
to do in a particular level.
And I think this is
also quite unrealistic.
You know, sometimes we do
better than at other times.
Depending on what we've been exposed
to, we might do better in certain
types of contexts than in others.
It's more or less the same idea.
We go from nothing, from
zero, to being launched.
And if we are a non-native speaker, there
will still be some jagged edges in our
language skill, even after we're launched.
And we just continue to
progress as long as we keep studying.
So when I'm a complete beginner, and
I might just demonstrate this sometime
at LingQ, because that's what I use
now, but before LingQ, what I would do
is, I would go out and buy two or three
different starter books, Teach Yourself,
Living Language, Colloquial, Assimil,
they're all the same in my opinion.
They have
a little lesson, they have a vocabulary
list for the lesson, and they
have some grammatical explanations
that you kind of look at. And you
work your way through the lesson.
And if you listen to that, and then the
next one and the next one, and then you
go back to the first one and you keep
doing that, eventually you start to
get a bit of a sense of the language.
Of course, by doing three different
books, I'm getting the same material
from three different sources.
It's what I often refer to as "grazing."
You're kind of covering the
same material in different ways.
That's a very effective way to learn.
Because if we are constantly using
the same book and trying to force
the same material into our brains,
the brain starts to lose interest.
As Spitzer always says, the brain likes
repetition, but the brain likes novelty.
So you keep it fresh
by changing the source.
You don't want to cover too broad a
range of vocabulary at the beginning.
You want it to be more or less...
It's high frequency vocabulary so
that there will be enough repetition
that you can kind of get somewhere.
I think any learning content we have,
you want to have enough of a mix of the
familiar with the new so that we're not
like everything is brand new. And
we have the feeling that we're trying
to learn things and no sooner have we
grabbed it, then it's gone, you know?
And that's how we designed the
Mini Stories. That there's in
each lesson, the same verbs, the
same words repeat five times.
We need this level of repetition at the
beginning. And the traditional starter
books that I used to use don't have
enough repetition. Because they take you
from the train station to the doctor's
office, to the hotel lobby or customs or
whatever they usually do in those books.
So as a beginner, I like to be in content
with high-frequency words, ideally with a
lot of repetition. And I end up listening
over and over and over again until I
start to get a toehold in the language.
That is the pattern.
And even after having completed one
of these beginner books, where they
promise you that you'll be at B1 or
B2, that's not the case. Because we
require so much input in the language.
And to the extent that we have
high-frequency vocabulary, that
means we're left with a lot of
lower-frequency vocabulary
that we still don't know.
And therefore we're very limited
in what we can listen to and read.
So it doesn't take you to B2 or
B1, but it takes you maybe to an A2
level in the language, if we stay
with the common European framework.
Now, if I'm going to study a language
that I'm at an intermediate level in,
there are two possible situations.
Either I'm in the midst of learning
that language, or it's a language
that I learned before and I left it
for a while and I'm going back to it.
The approach is essentially the same.
I want to go to content that is a little
bit challenging, but interesting to me.
Some of that, which I then vary
with something like the Mini
Stories with a lot of repetition.
I am particularly fond of Sentence Review
now at LingQ because now that I know more
about how the brain learns languages.
When we study sentence by sentence, we are
focusing more on that particular sentence.
And we can hear the sentence again,
and we're looking at words within
that sentence. And then we review
the words immediately after that sentence.
So there's a certain level of
frequency, a certain level of familiar
things, and all of that helps to
get those neurons firing together.
And then in the Sentence Review,
we were forced to reassemble the
sentence, which means drawing on our...
it's not exactly our memory because
we're looking at the words there.
But we're having to form a sentence.
The words have been scrambled.
We have to put them back together
again in their proper order.
It's a very good discipline for
becoming familiar with the structure
of the language and also sort of
renewing our acquaintance with
vocabulary that we have just met.
So I find that a tremendous exercise,
even in the initial stages, but
particularly as we progress to kind
of get that feel that you're getting a
good sense of how the language works.
I don't spend all my time doing
that because I spend a lot of time
just plain listening and reading,
you know. More of a top-down thing.
But I find that that "nuts and bolts, bits
and pieces" exercise is very effective.
That's kind of at the intermediate level.
But once you get past that, now
you're into audio book territory.
You're into reading books.
You're into extensive
exposure to the language.
And that's the only way you're
going to take yourself from that
"I have studied this language and I can
do a limited number of things in the
language" to being really comfortable.
And being a smooth speaker, writer, and
to be able to understand movies and so
forth. You have to consume a lot of it.
And that's the extensive stage.
That's the reward.
Every stage in the process is a reward.
I love doing my Sentence Review, even as
a beginner or as an intermediate learner.
But then eventually when I'm able to
enjoy books and movies and so forth,
that's where the big payback comes.